foreign
[Music]
so for those watching on YouTube I am
recording pretty late
so we're gonna do a 10 plus zero game
and uh the key change that I made late
in the speed run is that now I basically
play my actual repertoire so instead of
the accelerated Dragon I'm orienting
toward the night off here we're facing
Knight C3 which is the entry point to uh
the Grand Prix attack with that four
it's also the entry point to the closed
Sicilian with G3 and if you are a knight
or player then your move here is D6 and
I won't delve into an explanation of why
that is Bishop B5 check is a pretty
obscure sideline uh that has gained some
popularity obviously it's more common
after Knight F3 D6 then it's the canal
variation after Knight C3 I've seen it
as well but to be honest I don't know a
lot about it so I'm basically gonna play
the same way that I would play against
Knight F3 and actually we're transposing
into a line that we already have faced
we we face this line through the more
conventional move order that was the
speedrun game that I almost lost it was
one of our most fascinating games okay
so here our opponent plays it a little
bit differently he plays F4
instead of developing the Knight right
away to F3 okay well let's let's Force
White's hand with A6 I'm going to force
this bishop to commit commit to a
position it goes back to E2
and now we kind of have to solve the
problem of the light squared Bishop
ourselves
and I'm going to do that by simply
fiancatoing it on B7 and putting some
pressure on the E4 Pawn if you watch the
last video carefully you'll know that in
this situation you have to be very
careful about white pushing A5 uh
because that will make it very difficult
for us to then push our B Pawn without
allowing on passant when we're gonna
have an isolated and very weak a pawn
bishop to F3 okay so probably our
opponent is intending Bishop B7 E5 that
looks rather unpleasant
so I think that we're gonna strike in
the center ourselves we're gonna play
the move E5 and once again if you're a
night or player then you're not really
all that afraid of playing the move E5
if you're new to the Sicilian and you're
new to pawn structures in general you
might look at this move and say well
you're creating a huge hole on D5 but
we've already gone through this like the
whole on D5 is annoying but it's very
well covered by Black's pieces in
particular we're covering it with two of
our pieces at the same time the bishop
in the Knight which will make it very
difficult for white in the long run to
plant a knight on D5
so our opponent continues to develop uh
their pieces we are going to do the same
and we're going to get a very rich
position as a result very very
interesting structure G4 whoa
okay so our opponent initiates very
direct action on the king side and the
sort of general formula when your
opponent does stuff like this right
starts rushing in with a rapid fire King
side attack before even castling is to
do what like what's the very kind of
high level thing that you're supposed to
do when your opponent starts playing on
the flank without having completed their
development how does the principle go
what is the so the principle dictates
kind of two things either you play in
the center but more broadly you're
supposed to open up the center because
by opening up the center you sort of
underscore uh the underdeveloped nature
of your opponent's position so here the
Thematic move would of course be to play
D5 but D5 clearly doesn't work right
white just plays e takes D5 and we don't
have enough Defenders so instead what
we're gonna do is actually just take on
F4 and then we're immediately gonna plan
a night on E5 so we're not opening up
the center per se we're playing in the
center and by playing in the center
we're already highlighting the
vulnerable nature of uh these pieces
right by playing the move G4 white has
created an undefended Bishop on F3 and
White's position just seems very very
loose here okay so Knight G3 is an
excellent move
Now give me a second to think this is an
important moment
so we can take the bishop and secure the
bishop pair we can kind of tread water
by Castle in kingside which is actually
not such about a not such a bad idea or
we could play this very positionally and
we could actually make the move G6 which
I which I like which we're gonna make
in order to fully restrict this Knight
on G3 we've talked about this scenario
many many times when there's two squares
that separate a knight and a pawn in the
same file and that scenario is very
favorable for the side that has the pawn
because the Knight is restricted the
pawn acts kind of like a spike
and uh we're immobilizing the Knight so
we go G6
again this is a 10 minute game so I'm
commenting things a lot faster it is
quite late so I I apologize if the pace
is a little bit too frenetic for those
watching on YouTube but also that's kind
of what makes it fun
let's see how our opponent tries to
continue
his King side attack
nice position here for us
we're not worried about Bishop takes
Knight because we just recapture with a
pawn and and then we increase our
control over key squares in the center
right we get the bishop air we get the
dark squares and we get potential access
to the D4 Square for our queen or maybe
even later our Knight Bishop H6
so our opponent continues to try to
pound us on the king side and again if
we think about this thematically when
White's expending as much effort as he
is trying to prevent us from Castle in
kingside well okay there's still the
queen side and I can totally see us
castling the other way right going Queen
side where there are fewer pieces right
there there's fewer chaos and yeah we've
pushed some pawns on the queen side but
white doesn't have the Firepower I think
to exploit our King if it runs over to
the queen side so what are we gonna do
let's go Queen D7
and I think we're almost ready to Castle
queenside let's consider that for a
second yeah Castle's Queen side
okay there is the move G5
but I'm not too scared of the move G5 I
think we're gonna go Queen side here
actually maybe I should have been nah G5
we can drop our Knight back to E8 for
example
G5 we can drop our Knight back to E8 let
me up
okay sorry about that
okay so G5 is on the board now we have
to be very careful because if we drop
our Knight back to G8 we blunder The
Rook to Bishop G7 if we start by taking
the bishop then we allow the queen to
jump into position we definitely don't
want to do that so we definitely want to
drop our Knight back to E8 that's really
the only move
now the Knight 98 is not a great piece
but it can be very easily rerouted via
C7 potentially to E6 where it will then
pressure the G5 pawn and have access to
a nice Central Square on G4 important
tactical detail obviously Bishop G4 does
not win the queen anytime you have queen
king alignment on the same diagonal and
your bit your opponent possesses the
bishop of that color you have to be
extra careful but here the Knight does a
great job of taking the sting out of
Bishop G4 our opponent continues to
pound us on all sides of the board but
he continues to over extend himself
and of course we should take this Knight
and eliminate the outposts
and now
we should take a moment to think because
what are the biggest problems in our
position well one of the biggest
problems is this Knight but we don't
necessarily want to rush with Knight C7
are there any more creative ways that we
could try to involve this Knight and
potentially open up the position
well I'm looking at the move F5 here
and I really really like the appearance
of this move we're gonna go F5 then this
is a bit of a hard move to explain
briefly I'll try to explain it after the
game
among other things it creates first of
all this is a protected past Pawn so
this is a pretty major asset we're also
restricting the bishop but we're also
opening up this little Retreat Square
for our Knight which can suddenly drop
back to F7 and I'm eyeing this bishop on
construction and I'm seeing how
vulnerable it is right this bishop on H6
is just kind of stuck okay our opponent
takes on Passat but now the second idea
which is that our Knight has now jumped
back into the game Knight takes F6 the
center has opened up and White's King is
starting to feel very uncomfortable but
Bishop G2 by our opponent preparing to
Castle kingside man this guy is really
good
okay
I like the look of Knight H5 here
trying to open up the king side even
further
okay we can play bishop f8 and go for
the bishop trade but then our opponent
can drop back to G5 I like the look of
Knight H5 here
continuing to use our Knight as kind of
a battering ram
now of course this is a technically upon
sacrifice white can take twice on H5 but
one detail is that after Knight takes H5
we could potentially throw in a check on
H4
Force the king into the center and then
recapture the Knight but that might
actually be counterproductive because
the the closer White's King is to the
queen side the safer it's going to be so
after Knight takes H5 I think we're just
gonna take back
and hope for the best in that position
although I mean it's it's complicated
Bishop H4 has has its own appeal
ah Knight H5 might have been a mistake
but but I feel like we're continuing to
do everything within our power to to
punish white for keeping his King in the
center okay
yeah Knight H5 is a weird move but of
course the the actual idea is to open up
the G file
like the actual idea is to open up the G
file what's on the G file there's a
bishop on G2
and more importantly after White
Castle's King side White's King will be
on the G file so I'm basically
sacrificing upon and preparing for the
eventuality that White Castle's King
side and this is not a major Pawn right
this is just a g Pawn eh I don't think
it's going to be a big deal with as many
pieces on the board as we have
also kind of playing a little bit
against our opponent's clock here Knight
H5 is the kind of move that's going to
make anybody think for a while okay so
again Bishop H4 King D2
GH Queen H5 Rook G8 Bishop E4 that looks
yeah let's take on H5 let's make this a
little bit more open-ended for our
opponent because again less than four
minutes now you gotta keep an eye on
your opponent's clock in these
situations and oftentimes the more
open-ended moves are the ones which are
going to make people think for a little
bit longer
so what's going on in this position we
have a very powerful knight on E5 we
have a pretty compact structure let's go
Rook G8 I think
yeah let's go Rook G8 obviously this
hits the bishop this activates the rook
and white can still Castle yeah white
can definitely still Castle
but then he would be castling right into
a pin should P4 yeah man this is this
guy's very very very strong we have to
move our King over to B8 because the
threat was Bishop F5 and that did win
the queen B3
what an what a move preparing castling
Queen side okay
that's bold let's go Bishop F6
activating our Bishop activating our
Bishop putting it on the long diagonal
x-raying The Rook
and kind of goading white into castling
now the other way Castle in Queen side
but even if White Castle's Queen side
it's not the end of the story we can
still I think use our active minor
pieces in order to cause serious
practical problems to the white king
yeah definitely black is worse from an
objective standpoint but practically I
think White's position is very difficult
to play
and I'd definitely be interested in
exploring the earlier part of the game
with an engine because I did feel like I
got kind of outplayed but I don't know
exactly what I did wrong
so one idea that we have here is to go
C4 and blast open the entire Queen side
but that's sort of a more Brazen
approach to the position remember that
we're only down upon here so we don't
need to do anything Ultra drastic a more
measured way of trying to attack on the
queen side would be the move B5
right and you might look at me five and
you know I don't get how this is helping
us attack White's King well there's
steps to this right we we need to open
up a pathway to White's King and that's
what I'm trying to do with the move B5
if white plays a takes B5 think about
what piece you want to capture with do
you want to recapture with a queen do
you want to recapture with a pawn white
plays A5 and tries to keep the queen
side closed but now A5 itself has become
a very serious Target well can we attack
that Target I believe that we can we can
attack it by shifting Our Queen over to
C7 now the bishop controls A5 but we can
shove B4 down and cut off the connection
between the bishop and the pawn not only
are we threatening Queen takes A5 but
that comes with a tremendous threat of
Checkmate on A1 which means we can take
on A5 ignoring the threat of D takes C5
and suddenly we are the first ones to
create a checkmating threat and the
tactic tactics begin now what do I see
when I look at this position well one
important
thing to notice is the role that can
potentially be played by the mission
this bishop is controlling A1 if we can
remove the pawn from D4 the bishop and
the queen can combine
and potentially it can pose Unstoppable
threats of Checkmate on A1 so you might
say well let's move the Knight right
let's play Knight D7 and then we'll be
threatening Bishop takes D4 and that's
not a bad move but you can kind of use
the Knight as a flamethrower you can try
to say I'm going to use the Knight and
buy myself a tempo
so I'm Gonna Make a Move
that forces white to respond to it and
then I'm going to play Bishop takes D4
and create the mate thread on A1 so what
am I getting at like how do you use the
knight in the smartest possible way
well you can sacrifice it how can you
sacrifice it I like the look of Knight
C4 why does this Force white to take the
Knight well because we have a million
threats that we're posting with this
tonight Knight A3 check Knight takes D2
white basically has to take this Knight
then we play Bishop takes D4
we're threatening mate on A1 and white
has no good defense against that threat
I think the only thing white will be
able to do
after Bishop takes D4 is to play C3 but
then we just play BC and our King is
completely safe that's the main part of
this whole equation white isn't even
close to attacking our King so we have
all the time in the world to accumulate
the attack against whites King
crazy crazy game but I think we're
starting to gain the upper hand here
Bishop C1 what a move
that one I missed okay now wait a second
the point is Bishop takes D4 Rook takes
D4
and now we can play Knight A3 Chuck
Bishop takes a three Queen takes a three
looks very very strong for black
looks very strong for black is there
anything else that we could do
well we could try to deflect the bishop
with Rook G5 but White's not gonna take
it that's the problem
let's go Knight A3 check
now after Bishop takes A3 we could also
even take on A3 with the pawn and the
appeal of that is that it poses the
threat of Queen to C3
but Queen takes A3 creates the threat of
Bishop takes D4 and I don't see a
particularly good answer to that threat
let's go Queen takes A3 of course we
have to be very careful because now our
own King is kind of left to its own
devices now that the queen is kind of
hunting for gold on the queen side our
King is just sort of left there
and if white can find a way to generate
threats against the king the situation
becomes very double-edged but I don't
see a way for white to do that okay
Queen F7 looks very intimidating but I
don't really know what it does this move
looks very very intimidating but it
doesn't really create any concrete
threats in fact rather than myopically
just taking on D4 I think we have
potentially a game-winning combination
which I have to calculate
but we don't have much time to calculate
so I'm just gonna go with my intuition
and my intuition is to play the move C4
I want to drive the pawn down to C3 and
create a lobster pincer made on B2 or a
lollies made as it's more formally known
white has to take the pawn and then we
push B3 creating more made threats
against whites King this has to be
mating in my kind of tactical assessment
B takes A3
or C takes B3 let's grab this Pawn First
with a check
now let's find the mate now let's find
the mate oh I think I found it I think
all we need to do is shift our King over
to A8 I think the most clinical mating
move is to go King to A8
and the point is that if white plays
Rook B1 we had Queen A3 mate now
we take on D4 we deflect The Rook we
give a check we give another check we
give another check
and we deliver made on A1 or on B1
rather
wow
what an end to the game man that felt
like it was a bullet game but it
actually was a 10 minute game
crazy how how different a 10 minute game
feels even though this was originally
the speedrun time control it was 10
minutes
but now it feels like I was out of
breath from like move one
what a game okay a lot to look at for
sure
again for those watching on YouTube
this is a a somewhat more frenetic uh
speedrun than 15 plus 10 but
this is a popular time control so it's
not a bad idea for for people to know
what this feels like at a high level
and I definitely think there was enough
time to make decently high quality moves
great game by our opponent that that
came down to the wire and the tactics at
the end were really cool
so
again we're facing a non-mainline
sicilian which is ultra popular now I
think the open Sicilian with Knight F3
and D4 is perhaps less popular than it's
ever been which is not to say it's
unpopular I mean obviously people still
play it but you know all of these
anti-sicilians have gotten incredibly
incredibly popular so our move is D6
and now white delivers a check on B5
which is a it's an obscure line but I
faced it a couple of times uh at a
higher level in blitz so just to keep
this straight in your mind obviously the
the canal is Knight F3 D6 Bishop B5
check and this is a very reputable
system I've played this with white uh we
face this particular line with a four uh
a couple of games ago now you might say
well what difference does it make that
white has a knight on C3 instead of on
F3 well in certain instances it doesn't
make any difference at all
um you can conceivably come up with some
lines which transpose into a canal but
typically it's considered inaccurate for
white to commit the Knight to C3 too
early because in a lot of lines in the
canal in a lot of lines white actually
pushes that c Pawn either to C3 or even
to C4 trying to get kind of a morozi
bind setup so by by committing the
placement of the Knight to C3 white is
eliminating all of these possible plans
connected with the move C3 and C4 so
White's narrowing down their options a
little bit okay
so I'm gonna check the engine really
quickly after Bishop B5 check and see
what the computer thinks is the best way
to equalize here okay according to the
engine uh the best move here is actually
to play Bishop D7 not to play Knight t7
and this looks like a dead equal
position so after Bishop takes D7 Queen
takes D7 there's like hundreds of games
in the database Magnus has played this
with white
so Magnus has actually played this
system with white you go D4
CD4 and then Queen takes D4 very
computer-ish kind of idea Knight C6
and then the queen drops back to D3 this
has been played pretty extensively by a
lot of GMS
there's an azerbaijani Jam named gadir
gusainov who's a huge fan of this I see
a ton of his games in the database and
typically in such positions the way that
you want to develop with black is kind
of dragon Style with G6 typically in a
lot of these Canal positions you don't
want to go E6 because this is a little
bit passive you want to go G6
um and that's the main line G6 Knight F3
Bishop G7
White Castles I mean it's just an equal
position it's not nothing nothing to
write home about Knight F6 and now the
main line is Knight D5 now the main line
is Knight T5 black castles
white plays Bishop G5 trying to apply
pressure on the Knight on F6
and here
yeah here actually the engine gives
several ways to equalize the simplest
one is just to play Knight D5 and 95 and
force a bunch of minor pieces off the
board then the position is basically
dead equal
uh the only thing that you have to be
careful about with black in this
position
is just to make sure that actually you
can even play Bishop F6 and take the
last pair of minor pieces off the board
and this position may seem visually
slightly worse for black but in fact
it's completely equal because white has
no way to attack Black's weaknesses you
can always play off five the pawn on D5
is itself a little bit tender and you're
gonna gain e-file control by playing
Rook F to E8 so this is essentially a
dead draw I think
so this is a pretty boring line the
engine also gives a very interesting
uh type of idea which which is not
uncommon when you're trying to smoke out
the knight from D5 right so basically
the idea is that you cannot go E6
because you blunder the Knight on F6
right you can't do that
so what you sometimes do is you actually
move this Knight out of the way in order
to be able to play E6 and Chase the
Knight out of D5
and you can put that Knight on F6 on
several different squares you can play
Knight G4
but the problem with Knight G4 is that
you walk right into H3
you can play Knight H5
but then the Knight is kind of weirdly
on the rim although grishek did play
Knight H5 the engine actually likes the
move Knight to E8 which looks like the
most passive uh of Black's options
but the key thing to understand is that
after let's say white plays okay Z1
black plays E6 what is the role played
by the Knight on E8 the Knight on E8 is
a purely defensive piece but it's a very
important piece because it's guarding
the D6 spawn
okay and what does that allow black to
do that buys black Tempe
and black can use these Tempe to
generate very serious play on the king
side with the smooth F5 F5 is a very
powerful move
it has been played once
in the game Christopher you
against puya idani who's an Iranian GM
and black actually won the game
in that game after efgf
black just gets this very very nice Pawn
formation in the center
Christopher you played Knight C4
and here black moved the queen over to
F7 sacrificing the pawn on D6
but after E5 again Black's pawns are
starting to steamroll White in the
center the queen is very awkward and
Christopher you ended up losing the game
it's given all zeros by the engine so
that kind of is the main line
that's the main line of course
also possible if we rewind all the way
back to this position
is the move F4 which is kind of a
souped-up Grand Prix attack but it
doesn't make much sense to play a Grand
Prix attack structure without the light
squared Bishop because if you remember
in the traditional Grand Prix which goes
F4 Knight C6 Knight F3 G6 White's light
squared Bishop is an integral part of
their attacking scheme so to like trade
the Bishops and then say oh now I'm
gonna play a Grand Prix attack this just
looks completely innocuous and against
F4 I would probably just play the same
way that I would play against a Grand
Prix which is Knight C6 Knight F3 and
again you kind of adopt the dragon setup
so castles Bishop G7 D3 a lot of games
in the database here this is not a
particularly theoretically challenging
line and here I would adopt uh the
botvinic setup I would play I would play
E6
and then I would go Knight G to E7 which
is the setup that I've talked about
pretty extensively this is called the
batmanic setup and this uh essentially
takes the sting out of the move F5
although white can play F5 even in this
position Wesley so actually lost the
game here but the best line here is ef
ef and then just Knight G7
ef ef Knight G7 completing your
development FG
and actually you're supposed to play FG
opening up the f file because if white
tries to pounce with Knight G5 you just
send the Knight back with H6 and if
white plays Knight F7 this is actually
very very cool what do you think black
should do in this position where should
the Rook go where should the Rook go in
this position I'll let you think about
that for a second let me use the
bathroom real quick
yeah uh Rook H7 is the move
the move is Rook H7
now you should be aware
that in these types of situations you
actually can castle that is legal
that is legal but this only leads to a
draw
because White's Knight has an escape you
play King H7 now the Knight is hanging
so it has to go back to F7 you go back
to G8 and you get this hilarious
repetition but if you want to play for
an advantage you go Rook H7 and now the
Knight is stuck on F7
and as I've said many many many times
this is a situation that should raise a
tactical red flag
what situation am I talking about well
the the bigger the distance between two
pieces that are defending each other the
likelier it is that you're going to have
an interception tactic where you
literally stick a piece one of your
pieces between two of your opponent's
pieces
and of course
there are varying degrees of complexity
when it comes to this particular type of
theme here it's very simple right if you
identify the weak Link in White's
position you should quickly see that
Knight to F5 is going to be your next
move against almost anything that white
can throw at you particularly if white
plays for instance Bishop E3 then you
play Knight F5 and White's position is
in shambles why its position collapses
one example that I always like to show
on this topic of interposing is one of
my games
and I've shown this game
several times before in the speed run
but I like reusing examples because it
really allows us to hammer home
certain Concepts and I think that's not
done enough in chess instruction right
you're reusing examples constantly
looking at the same example
helps you hammer it into your head
so here it is
this is old game of mine from 2008
against an IM you can see I'm 2300 when
this game was played okay so this
position was reached and black is worse
than an end game
but I very confidently played Rook takes
F2 of course Very confidently thinking
that my opponent was born yesterday
completely missing White's next move
what did white do how do you note that
you have to look for something well
there's a vast distance between the two
Rooks that are defending each other this
screams interference tactic and once you
start looking for it you will find the
move Bishop to F3 intercepting the
turoks and it's easy to observe that
after GF King F2 very important notice
that the white Rook is protecting the
forking Square that's something that you
would have had to see while calculating
and When the Smoke Clears white is
simply up in exchange and winning the
game okay I took with the Rook but it
doesn't matter white is up in exchange
and I ended up losing the game so good
little tactical lesson here when the
distance between two pieces defending
each other is the bigger the distance
the higher the probability that
something is going to appear so where
were we yeah so this is like the
theoretical line with F4
so just to close off our our little
summary
I I think Bishop D7 is the safer move
I played a slightly more adventurous
move but Knight D7 appears to be
inaccurate in this particular version of
the canal the Knight on C3 according to
the engine Bishop D7 is just a much
safer move just something to file file
away if you are um studying the speed
run with an eye toward improving your
opening so it's a 97 which actually has
been played a lot by a lot of gyms so
it's not a mistake it just might not be
the best way to equalize okay so White
Blade A4
which is a very popular move nowadays in
these types of systems
expanding on the queen side and
preparing to push the pawn all the way
down to A5 and in so doing it makes it
difficult for black to operate on the
queen side like A4 is a is an ultra
positional move and at a lower level I
think a lot of people instinctively
respond with A6 and one of the more
concrete ideas of the move A4 is that
this can be met with Bishop takes D7
check and now what move that really
highlights the the Crux of white
strategy this is again purely positional
this has nothing to do with tactics this
is purely about Square control yeah
white plays A5 and you might look at
this and say well what's the big deal
and actually in this particular version
this is not a big deal so in response to
A6 in response to A6 I would probably
not take the Knight I would play Bishop
to C4 I would play Bishop to C4 and only
after a move like E6 would I consider
the move A5 clamping down on Black's
Pawn chain and making it very
undesirable for black to expand on the
queen side because of a takes B6 and now
you have to deal with this long-term
weakness on A6 you will see this type of
idea across many many many
different openings even in the king's
Indian right you think this has nothing
to do with the king's Indian but in the
king's Indian this is very standard fare
if we follow the main line of the king's
Indian
let's say we take the petrosion
variation right just random illustration
very frequently you will see that in the
king's Indian black has this Knight on
C5 and then black plays the move A5 in
order to prevent white from pushing B4
and less experienced King's Indian
players from the white side often
automatically play A3 while let's
reinforce the threat of B4 but here it's
the same concept black plays A4 exactly
the same thing white can still play B4
but it's Associated now with the
weakening of the A3 Pawn let alone the
fact that white would have to recapture
with the Knight
and uh allow Knight takes C4 uh which
loses a plot but again illustrating the
the more General concept here
if that makes sense so that's a good
application of the king's Indian
okay so A4 we decided to prioritize the
development of our King side pieces we
play Knight F6 white plays F4 which I
think is a very reasonable move that's a
more tactical way of uh of fighting for
the advantage here
and I still see games in the database
this is the main line actually F4 a
Wonder Liang had a game here with uh
with white against Anton core above a
lot of GM games still in this position
okay so A6
and Bishop back to E2 which is a very
very good move also possible was Bishop
C4
that was the a Wonder core above game
but Bishop E2 a couple of games in the
database including a game by a gadir
gusainov who is like the leading
specialist in this life so I actually
think that my next move might have been
a serious inaccuracy we played the move
B6
and the reason I played this move well
there's there's two reasons the first is
we wanted to deploy the light squared
Bishop to B7 and apply immediate
pressure on the E4 upon and I will be
honest I completely forgot about this
move in my mind I thought that white
would just continue developing with a
knight and now Black's plan is fully
Justified we played Bishop B7 or we
could even start with uh E6 and then
play Bishop B7 and black is completely
fine
according to the engine it's actually a
better idea to go at it from the other
side and to actually play G6 and I was
worried about allowing A5 but A5 is
really not such a big deal we can
continue to play chess here like Bishop
G7 Knight F3
and actually the engine after Castle's
castles the engine actually wants black
to play B5 anyway because it believes
that the activity garnered by this trade
is sufficient compensates for the
weakness created on A6 and obviously A6
is not the kind of weakness that's going
to decide the game right white is
probably best advised to play King H1
here and get out of the X-ray Bishop B7
D3 in the position is approximately
equal we could even expand on the queen
side a little bit with the move A5 it's
just a double-edged typical Sicilian
type position right nothing to write
home about but apparently G6 was a
little bit more accurate than the move
we played after Bishop F3 right away
white creates like very very concrete
problems for us uh because E5 is a huge
threat so if Bishop B7 then E5 literally
wins the game for white why does it win
the game for white well first of all you
cannot play de5 because the bishop has
you have to take the bishop white
recaptures with the Knight reinforcing
the E5 pawn and this is a very classic
scenario that you have to be super super
careful about where White's driving the
pond down and you're just not
sufficiently developed so for example
after D5 fe5 Knight G4 who can tell me
in this position what's a very thematic
kind of move that you always have to be
super super careful about allowing again
across many many different openings yeah
of course you automatically play E6 you
throw the pawn down to shatter Black's
King position and now you make the very
calm respond response Queen E2 in order
to control the E5 Square why is it
important to control the E5 Square
because if you play H3 you allow black
snide to jump back to E5 and kind of
diffuse the tension so Queen E2 is
actually a very typical follow-up and
black has no moves black is totally
buried here like there's just no way to
develop the bishop and and it's plus
three for white
so important detail there and that is
why I thought it was proper to strike
back at the center with E5 but I think
that in this position black is in fact
slightly worse White's got a very nice
compact Center
a nice way of developing the Knight to
E2 and uh of course black does have to
deal with the weakness of the D5 Square
uh in the long run
so anyways we play D5 uh and I still see
no so Bishop F3 is actually a novelty
according to the engine E5 D3
Bishop B7 Knight G2 Bishop B7 so here
we're both just developing our pieces
and of course the next big moment is
this very committal move G4 probably
with white I would try to play this a
little bit more positionally with
castles castles in something like Knight
G3 trying to get the Knight to F5
I would play this a little bit more
positionally from the white side but our
opponent really went Full Tilt with G4
okay so in response to play on the side
of the board you strike at the center
which is exactly what we're doing we
play e takes F4 Bishop F4 and we create
for ourselves a very nice Square uh for
the Knight on E5 in addition in addition
uh we by playing Knight t7 to E5 we open
up the D7 Square for the other night so
in the event that white plays G5 we
won't have to go all the way back to G8
and if you're a if you're a long
long-term Sicilian player then this kind
of idea should be pretty standard Fair
here is a game from many many years ago
where I fell victim to this exact idea
in a slightly different position so
watch this and this is how I knew to
play e takes F4 and Knight E5 so quickly
because I'm familiar with this idea so
you can see in this game I'm 1900 this
is a night or
and in this position
I prematurely played the move G4 trying
to get the king side attack started now
watch how similar this is black moves
away to D7 with the Knight and here I
make a follow-up mistake Bishop F3
now who can tell me from the black side
how black should punish white for
overextending too early on the king side
and
yeah there's a trick question here it's
not immediately E5
excellent
and pause the video if you're watching
on YouTube make sure that you are
actively engaged in this because these
are important ideas of the Sicilian that
you have to know if you want to play it
well okay so I see somebody suggesting
F5 but that just blunder Z6 with a fork
yeah so you play Knight takes D4 if you
start with E5 you're giving white you're
giving white the F5 score for no reason
so you start by playing Knight takes D4
and now you strike with E5 and suddenly
White's position falls apart F takes E5
Knight takes C5 and look at what black
has achieved black has achieved a
monster Knight black is achieved dark
Square control that prevents white from
pushing the Jeep on black has achieved
an open Center which really underscores
the weakness of White's King and Black's
position is now much easier to play so
this concept Knight takes D4 and E5 very
very similar you open up the E5 Square
for your knight in the game I did
something a little bit I position was
different so I played e takes F4 but
same type of idea to open up the E5
score in response to the move G4
okay
so
all right
so 95 Knight G3 G6
which is a pretty sensible move
controlling the F5 Square I think the
position is probably about equal here
that would be my very rough guess I
think the position is pretty
double-edged
um we played Queen D7
in order to hit the G4 pawn and prepare
to Castle Queen inside H3 Castle's Queen
side so this of course leads to very
very complicated struggle if you're
watching this and analyzing with an
engine in such positions which are not
well defined there's generally going to
be like three or four pretty decent
moves at every turn so for instance if
you flip the engine on you'll see that
Bishop f8 is possible you'll see that
Knight F to D7 is possible intending
Bishop G5 uh to trade off the the dark
scored Bishops and gain control over the
dark squares you'll see that a lot of
moves are possible we took a more direct
aggressive approach which is consistent
with my style but you could also play
this more positionally by moving the
Knight back and preparing to play Bishop
to G5
just finishing up a speeder in here
Queen to D7 H3 castles Queen side and G5
another very very committal move but I
think a very good one by our opponent
so again Knight G8 Bishop G7 loses the
rook and I didn't want to take this
bishop because I thought that the Knight
on E5 is kind of the pride and joy of
our position so I didn't really see a
reason to allow White's Queen to jump
into position particularly because in
that position we run the risk of losing
the F7 plot
okay so back to E8 we go
white sticks the Knight right in the
center of course we have to take it
and here
F5 okay so F5 is one of those pretty
thematic moves with the aim of
establishing a protected pass Pawn but
with the more primary aim of luring
white into taking on Passat so that we
could reactivate the Knight and so that
the Knight could do could be doing
something specific in this case
pressuring D5 does that make sense
Alternatives would include Bishop f8
Possible Trading off the Bishops and
putting the rook in position and on the
next move we definitely are going to
push the F Pawn in order to open up the
file for The Rook
so some of you might be looking at this
and saying well isn't G5 a serious
mistake because doesn't this put the
bishop in jail
yes it does but the placement of One
Piece does not determine the whole
evaluation
G5 has a very clearly defined minus in
that it imprisons the bishop but it also
has a couple of pluses in particular it
forces the Knight to the back rank so it
seriously hurts the coordination of
Black's pieces and it's going to take us
quite a few Moves In order to
re-establish that coordination and three
or four Tempe is very very valuable in a
position as complex as this one also the
bishop on H6 while imprisoned is not a
liability black can't win the bishop
right because it's always going to be
defended by this pawn and if white needs
to reinforce that pawn well white can
play H4 in the future okay so there's
just more to it than that and if you
just pick out one element of the
position oh well The Bishop's imprison's
White's worse that's not that doesn't
tell the whole story
95 takes takes that five white takes on
Passat we took back with a knight and
white decides to save their Bishop with
Bishop to G2 according to the engine
at least the chess.com engine
Knight takes F6 believe it or not was an
inaccuracy and I was supposed to
recapture with the bishop which to me is
very counterintuitive because that goes
against the whole purpose of playing F5
in the first place which is to
reactivate the Knight
but the point is that after Bishop to G2
black has a very concrete resource that
actually forces white to give up this
bishop so after Knight F6 Bishop G2
white was able to preserve the bishop
pair and that caused a lot of problems
for black
but after Bishop F6 Bishop G2 what
additional resource would black have
that really makes the move Bishop G2 a
big mistake this is all very very
intricate I know but it's the way that
it is right it's just the way that that
this position is
Bishop H4 is correct
Bishop H4 is correct creating a very
very unpleasant pin against the Knight
and forcing white to contort himself in
order to not lose material this is
already very very unpleasant
long story short
Bishop takes F6 creates this concrete
threat of Bishop H4 and so it it sort of
forces white to bail out into this end
game where black can grab an extra Pawn
on B2
so anyways
all of that is great white plays Bishop
G2 now we decided to sacrifice upon in
order to open up the G file but I
realized after Bishop E4 that we're kind
of running out of active ideas and I
also realized that white can prepare
castles Queen side so around here I
think black is worse but practically
it's very hard for a white to play
because white cat Castle
white would give up A4 and queen A1 be a
huge problem
white Kent Castle kingside because it's
illegal and we're controlling the G file
so in a way White's King is stranded in
the center and when you analyze such
positions with the engine you get a very
misleading you get a very misleading
picture of a position like this because
the engine gives Plus 0.89 or plus one
and it gives the move Rook F1 but Rook
F1 is a hard move to play right it
doesn't really seem to do anything and
black can keep accumulating the pressure
in the center with a move like Rook to
E8 creating that x-ray against the
e-file the engine also suggests actually
to Castle and to Simply Slide the king
over to B1
defending all of the squares all of the
infiltration squares along the a file
but would you like playing the position
with white after C4
with C3 to come I mean D4 C3 B3 and
apparently white is okay because Queen
A3 Bishop C1 and white actually wins so
you start analyzing and you start
realizing that from a practical
perspective White's position is still
quite difficult to play B3 Bishop F6
castles B5 continuing the pressure
continuing the pressure and white is
still better according to the engine but
after A5 Queen C7 I think this was the
turning point I think this was the point
at which White's Advantage evaporates
and at which black seizes the initiative
so apparently in this position the
engine move was Queen to F5 this was the
engine move forcing the queen trade well
it doesn't Force the queen trade black
can decline the queen trade with Queen
E7 but that lessens the pressure on the
A4 pawn and now white can play Rook hf1
and hit this bishop black has to go
Bishop G5 check and then Rook takes G5
and white insists on trading Queens with
Queen F6 with a better end game
obviously white is a better end game
because white is up a pawn we have a
very strong Knight on E5 so black has
good drawing chances but white is really
not risking here
so again it's these hard engine moves
that you have to find in very complex
positions and this is why it's hard for
the speedrun to have instructive value
at these higher levels because a lot of
it boils down to finding moves like
Queen F5
how do you find moves like this well you
have to just examine the position
concretely you have to see that there's
a lot of pressure on the A4 Pawn
and the best thing to do in situations
where your king is weak in the long run
is to trade Queens right that should
just kind of be on your bucket list and
if it's on your bucket list then Queen
F5 is a little bit more findable
in the game white played A5 we
immediately switch to the attack on A5
and of course our opponent missed B4 our
opponent missed B4 again interception
right this has been a theme of this game
interference we used upon stepping in
front of the bishop and creating the
Unstoppable threat of Queen takes A5 I
think after D4 the game is close to
being over
although amazingly here apparently
Knight to D3 was even stronger that's
crazy but we'll get to that in a second
according to the engine the only way for
white to Garner defensive chances would
have been to go the other way how
counter-intuitive is that you have to go
toward the center to D1 and E2
black is still better after Knight t7
but
I don't know any human who would not
assume that King B1 is the only way to
defend against the threat of Queen A1
mate crazy so apparently you had to make
space for the king to run in the other
direction which by the way is not an
uncommon defensive technique you should
remember that right when you feel like
your king
is busted on one side of the board a
very classic technique involves moving
away The Rook moving away the rook and
then making a Mad Dash for the king
toward uh toward the center or using
your actual King to make a Mad Dash
toward the center
and one uh very instructive example that
I gave in my book
many years ago is this position
where it is actually no that's the wrong
game
what's the right game but there we go
it's eliascus against Anderson
uh Grand Master game Let's flip the
board
so in this position black is under a
massive king-site attack and White's
last move was Rook to H3
what did Anderson do as the last resort
in this position
white wants to play Bishop F6 and queen
takes H7 Checkmate obviously H6 Bishop
H6 is game over immediately
so
what else remains but to run King G8 now
white obviously takes the Knight which
is a mistake and takes and King f8 and
King E7
and then Rook to D7 to make a little
envelope for the King on d8 black is
completely safe whites attack Fizzles
out and black ends up winning the game
okay
so I could show the rest of the game but
I'm just trying to illustrate a point
very similar concept
right so you're looking at this position
you're like oh no he's gonna play Queen
A5 and he's gonna stick the queen on A1
don't assume that the only way to go is
toward the attack you can also move away
the rook and make a little Escape Route
for the king to E2 and of course the
bishop on e4 plays a very important
defensive role without the bishop black
would have had this move slicing off the
Escape Route and setting up the threat
of ladder Checkmate but because white
has a monopoly over the light squares
this actually is a lot more feasible if
that makes sense
okay so after D4 Queen takes A5
obviously white can't take the Knight
because of checkmate
King to B1
and now Knight C4 now apparently this is
a little bit less accurate than Knight
to D3
because after Bishop D3 Bishop D4 it's
easy to observe that this Checkmate is
essentially Unstoppable white can play
C3 black plays PC and uh the threats
against White's King are overwhelming
there's this classic technique you give
away the pawn and you Checkmate on A2
so here white can resign Bishop B1
now you can play C2 check again and it's
the same exact concept
so what is the difference between
sticking the Knight on D3
and then playing Knight C4 so here
remember our opponent played this very
very powerful defensive move which I
missed what's the difference well here
if I plays Bishop C1 we can play Bishop
takes D4 and the Knight acts as an
umbrella it guards the bishop Against
The Rook whereas after Knight C4 Bishop
C1 this would be a horrible mistake
because white would be able to eliminate
the attacker and then eliminate the
other attacker and suddenly blacks
attack Fizzles out
another inter interference another
interception now this one is like a
second order interception it's not clear
what it is you're intercepting
until you actually look at the line does
that make sense umbrella Shield however
you want to call it you use the Knight
as a shield to guarantee safe passage uh
to to D4 for the black Bishop
crazy
Knight C4 Bishop C1 and the game
continues Knight A3 check still the
engine gives a near decisive Advantage
for for black and after Queen F7 C4 the
game is over
yeah I did everything correctly this is
winning but white could have stayed in
the game with the move Rook to D3
and after Bishop D4 white sacks The
Exchange and the game continues black
doesn't have an attack anymore so you're
just gonna have to evacuate your queen
and essentially convert this like you
would any material advantage but with a
past H Bond and an Airy King there's a
lot remaining to be done
so
White had to play this move Rook to D3
instead our opponent went for the
counter-offensive and allowed this very
very pretty decisive tactic with C4 of
course the idea is to play Lobster
pincer checkmate
and after BC Classic classic concept B3
right it's this concept of giving away
one pawn and then shoving the second one
down to the square vacated by your
opponent's Pawn this is a classic
attacking technique the point is after
Queen takes F6 to play a quiet move like
King to A8 with the Unstoppable plan of
Rook B8 and Black's just gonna have too
many threats against White's King
okay
um so C takes B3 is just game over
King A8 of course is is a quiet move but
I think an obvious move and then the
final male in the coffin of course Queen
A3 check and Rook B8 is possible but I
just wanted to eliminate White's Rook so
that this is guaranteed to be a ladder
mate if you go like this and like this
white can still white is still kicking
after King E2
so Rook takes D4 is a deflection
sacrifice to ensure that the white Rook
does not control any squares along the
second Rank and of course now you have a
much smoother ladder mate but there were
many many other mates as well so this
was just one of the possible wins
according to the engine Rook to G3 was
also a mating move because Rook B1 runs
into Bishop takes D4 with checkmate so
Rook G3 was even faster same idea Queen
A3 and Rook B3 same idea as king A8 to
open up a square so that the Rook can
jump into the attack
but Rook G3 is a really freaking pretty
move because if Queen takes F6 Shaq Shaq
and it's immediately made you don't even
need the ladder mate you just Checkmate
on B2
but this is not a very human move
because I think our human instinct is to
never allow a move like Rook to B1 but
Bishop takes D4 just supersedes uh the
pin against the black queen
so hopefully that makes sense after B3
the game is basically over according to
the engine white could have kept more
chances in this position
with like Rook to H2 and then you get
this line where the Rook comes into the
attack and black white runs and black
involves the other Rook this gets a
little bit messy but black is completely
winning it's like plus three a plus five
and white has to give up his Queen to
avoid getting checkmated
okay guys anyways I'm I'm pretty
exhausted this analysis took a little
bit longer than expected because we
focused a lot on the opening which I
think is really really important at
these higher levels so of course Bishop
D7 is a little bit safer
um the way that we played was somewhat
dubious with B6 and E5 but a very very
interesting game nonetheless a lot of
interesting Concepts highlighted and a
very chaotic chaotic middle game but I
think largely a well-played game no big
mistakes and really shows you the
importance of playing in a way that's
practically difficult for your opponent
even if you're worse for a lot of the
game I was able to keep the pressure on
and I was able to keep playing against
my opponent's king no matter where it
was on the chessboard and ultimately
that almost always pays dividends
I think you kill one Thunder for the
tier one
and Knight C4 of course is very pretty
but Knight T3 would have been even
prettier thanks guys I'm gonna get going
I do have a long day of travel ahead
tomorrow
so I will see everybody later
foreign
[Music]